last night you know yeah right huh uh
I'm Tyler
Richard Richard nice to meet you nice to
meet you yeah you new to this bar yeah
it's my first time here it's nice
awesome that's great I hate to be this
guy but ask you to take your hat off
right okay I get it cuz you're wearing
rules just like only one Fedora
per bar or party you know Wow you're
being serious if a king was to throw
some kind of royal masquerade and he
showed up wearing a crown and then a
random guy street just showed up to the
party to also wearing a crown people
would be confused are you calling
yourself a king okay look fedora the
explora I just don't want to have to
like box you up into a box and FedEx you
out of here because of fedora fedora I
get it okay who's judging us man no one
cares
yeah here k-fed listen I'm not taking
off this hat cuz you know what let's
dope on me all right and your hat let's
dope on you okay so can both wear hats
and look talk together I'm gonna give
you to the count of three men to either
get the H out or take the H off you know
what I know what I'll take it off I'll
take it off because you know what you're
right
I want to be more original you know when
you you know I know it I'm gonna take
the higher ground and I'm gonna take 400
really I am welcome George yeah welcome
to my bar man welcome my bar hey hey
this guy's a new fedora guy cuz I'm not
wearing a fedora anymore think about you
gotta be [ __ ] come on man come on